mer al ber d'être avec nous on va
répondre à toutes les questions le
mossade alors c'est le les services de
renseignement israélien sont réputés
comme les meilleurs services de
renseignement au monde est-ce qu'ils ont
failli d'abord on est souvent autoréputé
comme le meilleur du
monde si on faisait un sondage on est
peut-être pas sûr que les autres
services de renseignement a le même
point de vue et deuxièmement le mossade
n'est pas le service directement
concerné par ses affaires c'est plutôt
Laman le renseignement militaire ou le
shinbet qu'on appelle aussi le shabac
qui est le renseignement intérieur
puisque les territo occupé et la
situation précipitée de Gaza c'est à la
fois un pays à l'extérieur et un pays à
l'intérieur donc tout le monde s'en
occupe de le renseignement c'est trois
métiers et et trois cultures le premier
c'est la collecte du renseignement
personne n'a échoué au contraire il y a
énormément de renseignements et même des
renseignements publics fin juillet le
général benéiaou publie un document
expliquant que il va y avoir une attaque
frontale du Hamas contre Israël dans les
semaines qui suit fin août mon collègue
Carmon euh qui a fait à peu qui fait à
peu près avec israac Rabin ce que j'ai
pu faire dans le passé euh dit euh ça va
arriver entre fin septembre et début
octobre ça sera le Hamas et ça sera là
vous vous méprenez en pensant que ça va
être en sisjordanie ou dans le nord et
le para que les Égyptiens étaient au
courant aussi et le Haman dit le service
de renseignement militaire dit il va se
passer un truc on sait pas bien où mais
c'est plutôt euh au sud qu'au nord en
fait il s'est passé euh un un un premier
événement qui s'appelle euh on va dire
de l'enfumage euh c'est-à-dire que tout
le monde les aura laissé croire que ça
allait se passer en 6jordanie avec
beaucoup d'affrontements vers
l'esplanade des Mosquées de
nombreuses situations de tension et donc
l'armée d'Israël est remonté ses unités
du Sud vers le centre et vers le nord
pensant que ça serait le Hezbollah
beaucoup plus puissant qui lancerait
cette opération donc première opération
en fumage bah quand on vous ment on vous
ment évidemment vous êtes pas obligé d'y
croire mais là ils y ont cru ils ont
donc dégarni une très grosse partie de
leurs unités le deuxème événement c'est
un problème lié à l'organisation même de
l'armée en Israël c'est une armée
populaire c'est-àdire que réserviste par
réserviste soldat de métier ou pas en
fait tout le monde est un peu l'armé or
il y a une crise constitutionnelle en
Israël extrêmement grave entre le
gouvernement d'un côté et la la la la
société civile israélienne pour la
défense de ses droits constitutionnels
et donc les réservistes sont en grève
donc l'armée est dégarnie de ces forces
vives qui se renouvellent qui donne un
éclairage et notamment de ces analystes
qui ne sont pas des militaires au sens
de tout le monde est plus ou moins
militaire mais ils ont une mission qui
est non seulement de collecter de
l'information ce qui est très bien fait
mais de la comprendre de la hiérarchiser
et de s'en servir et ça c'est ce qui a
été vraiment l'élément qui n'a pas
fonctionné puisque une partie du réseau
qui permet de passer de la base au
sommet a été interrompu par la crise
constitutionnelle et la relation très
difficile qui existe avec le ministre de
la Sécurité d'État monsieur gvir qui est
considéré comme un ultra droit
extrémiste
agité provocateur ce qui fait qu'une
partie même des services de
renseignement officiel lui parlait plus
et donc remontait au cabinet du premier
ministre dans des conditions dont vous
imaginez à quel point elles ont été
détériorées par la situation enfin les
services de renseignement bah évidemment
de temps en temps il leur arrive de
faillir là ils ont merdé lamentablement
euh dans la mesure où s'ils
ont collecté de l'information ils l'ont
mal analysé et ils ont extrêmement mal
réagi et l'élément le plus
impressionnant de tout ce qu'on voit
là-bas c'est pas tellement l'attaque et
cetera c'est la prise du quartier
général de la division Gaza de l'armée
d'Israël par le Hamas quasiment sans
coup fait rire tellement elle était
désarmée et cet endroit est l'endroit
qui est le quartier général de la
riposte ce qui explique pourquoi ça a
mis des heures puisqu'il n'y avait plus
de quartier général et donc il y avait
plus d'information enfin et je peux vous
communiquer ça parce que c'est un
élément qui m'a été donné quasiment
quand je venais ici il semble euh que le
Hamas aidé par les passes d'Aran
iraniens et réussi à désactiver la
centrale d'alarme qui permettait de
savoir que le mur était cassé et donc en
fait les Israéliens étaient aveugles et
sourd ce qui est tout à fait inédit
alors même qui pensit avoir par
fétichisme technologique une un système
extrêmement performant enfin si je peux
terminer là-dessus les agents de
renseignement israélien infiltrés en
Palestine et beaucoup de Palestiniens
eux-mêmes ont été éliminés de manière
extrêmement méthodique par le Hamas
depuis des mois des mois c'est un vrai
opération ou retourner et ont donc soit
enfumé les Israéliens soit ils ont perdu
leur capteur donc le cumul de tous ces
événements plus une opportunité
historique qui était la fête de
sououscotte le fait qu'il y avait
personne la r parti et la crise
politique en Israël a permis la réussite
d'une attaque qui est préparée depuis
des mois notamment les stocks non pas de
roquett mais de missile parce que tout
le monde impression que la roquette
c'est un espèce de de petit feu
d'artifice nous vous avez vu où
jusqu'ils vont notamment Jérusalem ce
sont des véritables missiles dont le
niveau de technicité a beaucoup
progressé en fait aujourd'hui le Hamas
donc tout le monde pensait que c'était
une bande de vanupi palestinien et
l'équivalent du hzbollah une armée
milicienne extrêmement structurée et
organisée capable de cette opération
multitâche alors la seule qui a échoué
c'est l'attaque par la mer reste il en
reste pas moins mon cher Allin quand
même que on a d'un côté une armée dont
les super pouvoirs technologiques font
absolument la fierté de de salle et
c'est vrai que Israël a toujours été
considéré comme une armée ultraoderne et
comme à chaque fois dans jardinattentat
on a en face des gens qui arrivent avec
leur couteau et de trois ULM et donc il
y a aussi peut-être aussi cette
disproportion entrere capable de de de
prévoir et de parer le pire de la
technologie mais pas le couteau qui
arrive à porter de main oui c'est c'est
ce que j'indiquis c'est le le problème
de l'arrogance et du fétichisme
technologique et de ne plus avoir ni de
capteur humain ni d'éléments qui
permettent d'analyser les signaux di
faibl alors il y en avit beaucoup
beaucoup hein ils sont pas aussi faibles
que ce qu'on raconte la commission
d'enquête israélienne révélera à peu
près ce qu'on a appris sur le 11
septembre on savait tout on a rien
compris on s'est fait avoir est-ce qu'il
y a pas une forme de somnolance Cyril
aussi c'est-à-dire là je pose la
question aussi à vous tpecteur mais je
je pense qu'ussi ce qui se passe
actuellement et les problèmes qu'il y a
en Israël et notamment les problèmes
politiques font que le premier ministre
israélien a été aussi un petit peu
défaillantup il s'occupaent d'autre
choseant il était pas sur le coup on l'a
mis sachez que de ce que je sais tu vas
me dire alin si je dis une connerie il a
été mis en Garf plusieurs fois on lui a
dit plusieurs fois attention et il
s'occupait plutôt des problèmes internes
en fait que pour cy en fait il s'est
passé un événement c'est que chaque fois
que l'information arrivait notamment par
l'ancien chef d'état-major beniaou c'est
pas n'importe qui c'est pas un général
d'opérette on disait ah oui mais tout ça
c'est pour nous forcer à revenir sur nos
positions afin de résoudre la crise
constitutionnelle et en fait c'est vous
nous enfumeer en nous disant qu'on
risque au sud alors que c'est pas vrai
et donc c'est un cumule c'est ça
d'opportunité qui serv on voit on voit
les drames que peuvent causer oui la
politique mais c'est aussi la petite
politique exactement la petite politique
aussi le fait que lorsquisraël s'endort
au volant quand une forme de somnolence
l'ennemi le sent instinctivement et ça
ne rate pas non mais ça fait plusieurs
ça fait plusieurs mois que a des soucis
et que voilà Israël est plus défaillant
que les anciens chefs du renseignement
les anciens chefs d'étatmjant ont publié
à plusieurs reprises des tribunes c'est
ça dans la presse israélienne c'est pas
des documents secrets on peut les lire y
compris pas seulement en hébreux on dire
attention il y a une destruction de
l'unité nationale israélenne la sécurité
nationale du pays est est en péril à
cause de vos petites manœuvres
politiques et disant faut quand même
arrêter le ministre de la Défense
lui-même qui mène la contreofensive a
été démis de ses fonctions car il s'est
élevé contre la politique de de son
propre Premier ministre sur cette
affaire donc c'est pas une affaire
secrète ni clandestine mais ça ouvre un
espace on s'occupe pas de ce sujet on
s'occupe d'un autre on se fait en fumer
on perd ses capteurs on sous-estime
l'adversaire une forme d'arrogance aussi
et puis on considère que les palestinien
c'était grosso modo une variable
d'ajustement dans la grande opération
qui était bon les accords de scos c'est
fini les deux états on tous semblant d'y
croire mais en fait tout le monde
pensait que c'était terminé par contre
les accords d'Abraham le rapprochement
avec l'Arabie Saoudite ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure était le grand
nouveau et que les Palestiniens bah
comme d'habitude feraient comme ça or
l'Iran dont il faut jamais sous-estimer
les capacités les compétences le
professionnalisme l'art de la
manipulation et y compris la pénétration
dans les réseaux je pense d'ailleurs que
une partie des professionnels qui sont
intervenus à Gaza au début sont pas tous
des Palestiniens de souche comme on
dirait bref tous ces élément là ont pris
Israël à revers mais Israël a aussi en
partie construit par une certaine forme
d'arrogance et de som je suis assez
d'accord avec le mot la la possibilité
de les les les gouvernants israéliens
oui bien sûr exaement alors on va on va
passer à la deuxème question quelleelles
pourraent être les répercussions en
France alors il faut savoir qu'en France
depuis 1980 nous avons régulièrement des
attentats qui ne sont pas liés à la
politique française mais aux affaires du
Proche Orient à la rue Copernic la
première fois évidemment la rue des
rosers ensuite c'est en 82 et puis
régulièrement on a ça alors les Iraniens
les libiens les
Syriens
les Iraniens viennent régler un certain
nombre de comptes chez nous soit entre
eux soit contre la politique de la
France et je vous passe l'attentat
contre le dracar à Beyrouth qui est le
pire attentat que la France est connu
avant le Bataclan donc le risque existe
le problème il est exactement ce que
vous avez essayé de démontrer au début
et j'ai vraiment beaucoup apprécié à la
fois la la sobriété la gravité du temps
que vous avez utilisé c'est-à-dire
l'utilisation des communautés nationales
existantes autour d'une religion pour
les faire se battre au nom d'une
idéologie car de des facto je le
rappelle assez souvent d'ailleurs le
drapeau du Hamas n'est pas le drapeau de
la Palestine pas du tout il est même
extrêmement différent c'est un autre
drapeau il y a des raisons pour cela
parce que c'est une organisation
frériste qui a une logique qui lui est
propre qui n'a rien à voir avec y
compris parfois ce que disent les
Palestiniens y compris l'aile la plus
marchante le FPLP enfin les anciennes
organisations les plus dures le Djihad
islamique a à peu près la même opp mais
s'est fait dépasser par les événements
mais ils ont une trentaine d'otage aussi
faut pas les sous-estimer dans ces
affaires puisque pour la première fois
dans l'histoire il y a une coordination
assumée le 2 septembre il y a même une
photo comme quoi le secret n'est plus ce
qu'il était qui montre que l'Iran le
diihad islamique et le Hamas et le
Hezbollah se réunissent à Beyrouth pour
coordonner les opérations contre Israël
et le Hamas contre les Juifs car
effectivement il y a quelques nuances
alors très très nuancé hein mais il y en
a qui sont contre Israël et d'autres qui
sont directement contre les Juifs et le
Hamas a toujours eu cette spécificité de
toujours expliquer que il fallait
éradiquer les Juifs et pas seulement
supprimer l'état eux ils sont
antisémites et antisionites et ils
assument cette position malgré de temps
en temps des petits donc la France elle
est toujours au cœur de difficultés
majeures à cause de son son ancienne
politique arabe de son amitié pour
Israël de ses propres contradictions
nombreuses mais elle a un avantage son
amitié avec le Qatar peut permettre et
ça d'ailleurs commencé une négociation
pour les otages et pour la libération
des otages et ce moment-là c'est le bon
moment de la France je pense qu'elle n'a
pas à entrer dans des pérégrinations
incompréhensibles sur C'est la faute
machin ça de toute façon un enfant mort
c'est un enfant Mor il a ni drapeau ni
machin il est insupportable quoi qu'il
en soit mais dans la réalité la France
elle peut entrer dans un processus en
poussant le Qatar à une libération
massive des otages parce que le Qatar
c'est quand même ceux qui font les fins
de mois du Hamas c'est parce qu'ils ont
arrêté les fins de mois en tout cas
qu'ils n'ont pas payé autant que ce que
le Hamas demandait il demandait une
petite prime inflation et donc le Qatar
a refusé ce qui explique aussi une
partie des sujets et puis dernièrement
il y a une guerre à l'intérieur du Hamas
car aujourd'hui c'est la victoire de
monsieur simvar qui est le patron du
Hamas à Gaza alors que les grands
patrons du Hamas ne sont pas à Gaza ils
sont à Damas ils sont à beyouth il leur
arrive d'être parfis les enfants sont
dans les grandes
écoles mais il y a aujourd'hui une
guerre du plus dur encore plus dur c'est
il y a pas vraiment de modéré
entendons-nous bien mais disons qu'il y
en a qui étaient prêt à une sorte de nég
ition sur les frontières de 67 ou pas là
il y a une guerre aussi interne au Hamas
et là il y a un coup qui a été marqué
c'est nous sommes capables de monter une
opération massive avec près d'un millier
d'hommes attaquant par mer par air et
par terre prenant des otages prenant le
siège le quartier général de la division
Gaza de tsal et ça c'est un événement
historique qui change la psyché c'estàd
la psychologie générale de la la fois
l'invulnérabilité supposée d'Israël qui
est tombée voilà là il fallir la
reconstruire mais aussi l'Occident qui
est directement visé car dans cette
affaire derrière Israël il y a nous mais
est-ce que le Hamas vient pas de se
tirer une balle dans le pied puisque
normalement ils vont être éradiquer ils
peuvent plus continuer ces suicidaires
ça existe pas l'éradication
hein j'ai passé ma vie à commenter les
les les élimination supposée de de
alqaïda enfin ce qu'on croit devoir
appeler alkaaïda ils sont toujours là
donc non non l'éradication c'est quand
tu règles le problème pas les effets du
problème les causes et pas seulement les
conséquences alors